what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with Marvel legacy
the cool thing now is that we're getting
into like February March April which
means a lot of these storylines are
starting to wrap up a lot of these are
basically starting to come to an end to
the point we can actually start going
through and covering a lot of these
things that's kind of the downside to an
Marvel legacy launch because so few
people were watching videos that I was
uploading on like all-new all-different
marvel or Marvel now 2.0 we kind of had
a way to a more of a legacy kicked off
in order to really go back and start
covering a lot of this stuff and so when
it comes to old man Logan again this is
cool I mean this is one of those things
were you know writer ed Burris and kind
of picks up the whole run of Jeff Lemire
and does it in spectacular fashion I
mean it's really cool the way it's done
but the cool thing about this too is
that it also kind of delves into the
history of old man Logan remember that
was kind of the cool thing about his
character is all we really knew was he
hailed from a universe where the
villains killed all the superheroes and
he was one of the last few people who
had survived he had killed all the x-men
you know after being tricked by Mysterio
and again when we have a huge playlist
on x-men stuff that you're welcome to go
back and look at but by and large one of
the things that Marvel never really
explored here was like the origin of old
man Logan they did to a degree but we
were largely largely left just kind of
assumed that the origin of old man Logan
is almost identical to the origin of the
old classic Wolverine and it is kind of
interesting because we get these little
confirmations here and there but then we
also get these small moments where
things are a little bit different but
what this does is this initially picks
up in Tokyo you know in Japan nothing
really out of the ordinary
right off the bat anyway I mean it's
just a handful of guys who throw some
guy out of a bar and they're just kind
of talking trash but he oh yeah this is
part of the scene of Wolverine of like
old man Logan you know the criminal
underworld that kind of a thing but when
they attack old man Logan one of them
basically begins to heal and that's when
the initial indication is given that
okay maybe this is a mutant this is a
new kid on the block so I'm glad this
got a healing factor but then Wolverine
you know basically the story tells us
that old man Logan realizes this guy is
not an inhuman and he's not a mutant and
so what that means is he gained his
powers by some other source now at this
point we pick up with the Yashida
corporation now and here's a funny thing
I actually had a tweet out because I
wasn't sure what happened to the
original silver samurai and apparently
he died in 2010 and like Wolverine vol 4
which I never realized and for the most
part when it came to like the original
silver samurai Harada
when it comes to like shin Harada they
are really more like stewards of the
Ishida clan did anything else and the
reason why is because it is a monarch is
it's a monarchy basically in the sense
that what you end up having is
idea that the original shingen yashida
basically started clan Yashida
he started this massive corporation and
then it was supposed to pass down from
one generation to the next now it did
past him to mariko yashida and then she
was killed and so from there the company
went to control of her half-brother
the original silver samurai and then
after his death it went to his his
illegitimate son shin Harada ah but as
if somebody with like somebody with you
know part of the Yashida bloodline were
to come along and say I'm retaking
control of this company
there's nothing shin could do to stop
them because they legally have control
of that company he and the various
Hirata's are really more like caretakers
than anything else until a member of the
Yashida clan comes along with the
correct bloodline so again it is kind of
interesting here but the one did he keep
in mind is that we end up having this
guy named touka who's basically being
confronted by shen and the reason for
this is because of the fact that they've
been developing or at least saw Yoshida
Corporation has been developing
something called regenexx which is
basically a drug that allows people to
regenerate now the other thing to
remember here is that Shin is pretty
cutthroat and the reason why is because
once he finds out this guy's stealing
from the company he just drops him off
of a building and that's really about it
and so it gets pretty brutal from there
because this really just kind of like
these two cross these two paths crossing
one another because old man Logan
follows along and then ultimately comes
across this you know crazy clan as they
call themselves crazy gang clan whatever
it is they call themselves a crazy
Thunder clan there we go
and it's basically them just kind of
making a massive shipment that's gonna
go to mad rapport of course Matt rapport
is we know being like this huge criminal
underworld that exists out there this
you know a place where all the criminals
just kind of stay and hang out and so on
and so forth now the battle to follow
suit is pretty par for the course I mean
it's pretty straightforward not a whole
lot going on there it's basically this
idea of old man Logan fighting against
these various you know guys that are
using regenexx and that's really about
it the caveat to this is that the fight
makes its way into a cooler and that's
what Wolverine begins the world man
Logan begins to realize that cool air
actually slows down the healing factor
of the abilities of rigidity which
basically grants them a reprieve and
essentially threatening one of these
guys is saying look you know I'll cut
your head off and then yeah you'll dive
and that'll be about it and of course
the guy spills the beans and says hey
look here's everything that's going on
and we bought it from this guy who
worked for Clan Yashida and so on and so
forth and so switching back to Shin this
is when things start to pick up and the
reason why is because while he's in his
office you know conducting business
suddenly he's met by the arrival of the
hand now we've talked about the hand
before in Marvel Comics and they're
pretty extreme those of you guys who are
not familiar with the
way back well really the origins the
word is kind of fluctuating I mean
really it was like a billion years ago
you kind of had these guys who worship
the great evil Beast you know or I guess
really just the beast as they call them
but in terms of the actual hand as it
exists now that probably dates back more
to like the 10th or 11th centuries and
it was this idea that there was a guy
named Coggan Abu Yoshioka who basically
grabbed all these different villages
that were that really didn't like the
Japanese government at the time banded
them all together took them to the
mountains and then unified them under
his control and rechristen the group the
hand from that point it was delving into
like mysticism things like that because
they already had a strong understanding
of like the samurai code and martial
arts and all different kinds of things
so they already knew how to fight
effectively and so that's kind of how
the hand rose to prominence now the
other half of this is the hand is
currently being led by Gorgon now Gorgon
is a relatively new character I mean he
was created back in 2004 and like
Wolverine vol 3 issue number 20 and he
was created by Mark Millar and Gorgon is
basically just a guy named Tommy Xie xiè
Asha Shido
I think it's how you pronounce his last
name ah but he's kind of he's basically
a mutant he has like low-level telepathy
which means he can like read and
somewhat influenced the minds of others
but it's really more just reading the
minds of others a combined with the fact
that he has what's called the Gorgon
Stare meaning if Gorgon were to remove
the bandage from around his eyes he
would just turn to stone everything that
he looks at every single order you know
organic organism or what-have-you
that he looks at would turn into stone
and that's why he keeps his eyes
bandaged now and truth his telepathy
whether you know seeing through the eyes
of others or what-have-you allow him to
you know basically function of course
he's also an exceedingly smart human
being that's the funny thing about this
is that Morgan's not just a soldier
who's just really good at sword fighting
he's he's insanely intelligent I mean it
like four or five years old
he was classified as like a world-class
genius so I mean he's really really
smart in terms of the schemes that he
pulls the problem with this is that for
the most part he's usually relegated to
a background character he really is
nothing more than just a henchman and
almost every single story that he's been
written in which is kind of
disappointing because of how Marvel you
know how Mark Miller originally built
him out there's no reason he shouldn't
be one of the most formidable villains
out there the question is how do you use
a guy like that in a villain role that
is that formidable which is kind of
interesting but the other half of this
is that when it comes to shinja Ronda
one thing to bear in mind is that he is
very much arrogant he's very cocky he's
very you know youthful and powerful in
that regard so the result is that where
he is able to
take out all these members of the hand
pretty quickly what we end up finding
out is this was a distraction and in
fact it was a distraction from someone
called the Scarlet samurai which of
course basically leads to him being
impaled and that's really about it I
mean you know just more or less kind of
defeated you know pretty quickly and
essentially killed off and so what we
end up doing is we end up jumping back
to you know a period before this story
starts and we pick up with Gorgon going
through the process of resurrection the
hands resurrection process is a way for
Marvel to basically bring back
characters that normally would stay dead
I mean that's that's the whole thing
like they legitimately die and then
Marvel wants to bring them back
sometimes the hand will be the ones to
do it now the other half of this is that
Gorgon scheme here is really just trying
to find a way to reproduce regenexx is
really all it is and so breaking into
Clan Yashida basically taking it over
somebody saying that you know Gorgon
himself alongside the scholar Samurai
they're the ones running the show they
begin the process of using regenexx on
various hand soldiers this is a pretty
big deal because instead of someone like
Wolverine just tearing through all these
members of the hand cutting them to
pieces and calling it a day what this
would mean is that they can basically
heal so as long as they're not in a
place that's exceedingly cold like if
they're not fighting in the Arctic or
something along those lines then they'll
be virtually no way to stop the hand and
that was a whole basis behind it or at
least one of the many practical
applications that could be used for it
now of course with old man Logan himself
having a conversation with the widow of
earth to go this of course leads to
Gorgon and skull samurai showing up at a
pretty significant fight breaking out
between all of them and this is when old
man Logan begins to realize these
various members of the hand are using
regenexx not only that in the middle of
this fight that he engages in with
scarlet samurai he actually loses his
hand which is a pretty big moment
because what this basically means is
that he you know this this weapon that
scholar samurais using can cut directly
through adamantium now what this
material is I'm not entirely sure maybe
it's some sort of Arctic vibranium
because as it stands in Marvel Comics
nothing should be able to cut through
adamantium Arctic vibranium can cut
through adamantium just because of the
fact that it breaks down the adamantium
metal and like the atomic level you know
is effectively separating the atoms from
one another thereby eliminating
vibranium in its entirety because the
molecules that make up in the adamantium
itself begins to just kind of fall apart
at the seams and so that's really kind
of the only thing that I can think of
but we're not explicitly told here so
either this is a pretty large oversight
or it's the introduction of something
new but it is kind of intriguing because
what we of course end up finding out is
it
chin Harada had basically survived this
entire experience a being like stab to
the chest and thrown into the garbage
now again this is another one of those
interesting scenarios because Jim Harada
is exceedingly intelligent but he has no
powers at least not that I'm aware of he
doesn't have any real abilities
whatsoever he's just a really really
skilled swordsman so we're just kind of
chalked up to the idea of hey this is
just one of the things they plan for
with the various contingencies I mean
it's very much just kind of asking us to
take things at face value now it does
create for somewhat of an interesting
scenario and it does really ask some
questions it kind of keeps us on board
with regards to you well how in the
world is all this stuff being pulled off
now of course this leads directly to you
know old man Logan basically racing off
because remember when it comes to his
healing factor it's not like it used to
be I mean his hand is effectively
growing back it's just not as strong as
a healing factor used to be now again
this really kind of brings into sharp
relief the nature of his healing factor
and we've talked about that in a
separate video but just for the folks
who are kind of new here the best
example I was ever able to use and
explaining how disability works when it
comes to Wolverine is like a hammer if I
say hey look here's a hammer that's
pretty light and here is a nail and I
want you to just start hammering this
nail eventually your arm will get tired
and that's what Wolverines healing
factor does it's not infinite because of
the fact that he has adamantium in his
body barring the idea that it'll poison
him or him losing his healing factor or
something like that under normal
circumstances where there's no type of
you know additional harm to his body or
anything that it can't compensate for if
he lives a long and healthy life
eventually his healing factor will just
tire out and then eventually it'll it
won't be able to stop the adamantium is
poisoning his body again that's kind of
the whole idea that goes on here but
what we end up having is old man Logan
you know coming back into contact with
shin Harada again and shin Harada
basically explains a whole backstory
behind this that in truth the idea of
regenexx was never designed to be like a
street drug he was never designed to be
something that would be peddled to the
highest bidder
it was basically a drug that would be
designed to make the world a better
place at the same time it was also
designed to make Shin a lot of money too
so I mean that was the whole purpose
behind it was to say hey look this drug
could be used by you know for military
applications went you know military
officials sent soldiers into the field
they give him temporary healing factors
so they can fight longer they can fight
harder that was the whole idea behind it
was to essentially usher in a new a new
a better world now the problem with this
is not only have the hand taken regenexx
and used it for themselves at least what
little samples were left this shipment
that was supposed to that you over
initially stopped at the beginning
that's been sent off to majeure port
what it means is that not only in people
in majeure poor gonna be able to get the
serum somebody's going to
reverse-engineer it and so somebody in
turn is going to probably duplicate it
and then sell it out there on the market
itself which ushered in a whole new
world of problems but again because of
the fact that old man Logan had figured
out that cold is basically the best way
to essentially slow down the effects of
regenexx when he and shin Harada
basically make their move against Gorgon
and the scholar Samurai and the hand
they throw in this giant tank of liquid
nitrogen which is actually kind of cool
again this is really something like old
man Logan would do I wouldn't really see
this being something that Wolverine
would do and that's kind of a distinct
difference between these two methods of
storytelling if this story was told in
like 1995 for example Wolverine would
just run in there with his claws popped
and just tear that tear of the hand
apart you know probably kill Gorgon and
tear apart you know scholar samurai
assuming they even managed to survive
this long with old man Logan his healing
factor you know has to be compensated by
his intelligence so that he can
basically make up for this now weakness
that he has as opposed to a strength
that he used to have so it is kind of
cool because with him showing up and
facing off I mean the hand they're made
of you know they're made pretty quick
work of just because of the fact that
the whole liquid nitrogen kind of cools
the place down enough other healing
factors aren't really effective anymore
and then at that point it's turning his
attention to two two scholar samurai now
this is kind of a big deal because what
we had found before was that Scarlett
Samurai was actually a girl named Mariko
and I wanted to wait until this moment
to talk about that when it comes to the
character of Mariko she's probably the
most significant love interest of
Wolverton the reason why is because
she's really like the first that
mattered I mean Wolverine had had love
interest over the course of his life but
Mariko was really the first time that
Wolverine had sat down and entertained
the idea of walking away from this life
that he lived what he wanted was to
basically start a family now of course
that never really happened each soo was
the person that he had taken with but
for the character of Mariko it was more
or less just like hey look there's a
life better than this and in fact he had
that four-time ultimately Marika was
poisoned Wolverine had to kill her in a
mercy killing but again we're grabbing a
lot of this stuff from the main Marvel
line of comics and just kind of rolling
that history over an old man Logan
because there's nothing to indicate that
didn't happen and so because of that
with him having to face off against
Mariko like this there is one part of
him is kind of like hey look you have to
come back but the other part is well
maybe she can't be saved he has to kill
her because otherwise she's gonna kill
him
and it's a totally different
circumstance and it's really really wild
in terms of how it plays out because he
has to come back these two things now
whole point of old man Logan is to like
move on from the past right like to not
be locked in the way things used to be
which is a very difficult thing to do
and that's what old man Logan was trying
to avoid he was stuck in the wastelands
he was stuck in the family that he used
to have he was stuck in trying to get
back he was always trying to go back but
there is no going back you can't go back
to the way things used to be because
that's the way things used to be it's
not the way they are now and this is
really one of those the kind of
continuation of the Jeff Lemire saga of
the past of old man Logan is always
coming back it's always coming back to
haunt him in this instance it's a
resurrection Mariko and so it is
interesting because what is it happening
here is of course Gorgon basically just
leaves he'd essentially takes off just
kind of jumps out the window and says
I'll see you next time and that's really
about the end of him and then of course
Shen knocks out knocks out Mariko
largely because you know oh man Logan
asked him not to kill her if it came
down to it and so again what this does
is it allows for a continuation between
these two characters it allows adverse
animation we say look the story's going
to pick up with these two because now
the most significant love interest of
Oban Logan's life is back and this is
cool because what it does is it sets the
stage for the future of his character
one of the big questions people have
right now is what's going to happen when
old man Logan meets classic will rain
because that story's gonna happen
eventually and what will happen with
classic will rain returns back to being
part of the x-men and so on and so forth
you know what happens when all that
because it wouldn't make any sense to
say hey guys classic Wolverines back and
now he's dead it wouldn't make a whole
lot of sense to do that so like he's
back he's gonna be here for awhile which
means you could possibly have - you know
- Wolverines but if you couldn't have -
Captain America's I don't see what
people would say you could have two
Wolverines so in that instance
something's gonna have to happen to old
man Logan like he's probably gonna have
to go away which would be disappointing
but this would allow for that right like
Mariko finally returns to normal and old
man Logan says look I want to live now
let's settle down let's go start a
family and I'll just be out of the
picture and I'll never be seen or heard
from a Marvel comics again I have no
idea but it does kind of tease that
possibility the orders to use an idea
because what is up happening is that at
this last little tidbit Shin basically
tasks old man Logan and N and Mariko
with going to mad rapport and basically
siphoning out and eliminating the last
little bit of regenexx or at least to
bring some back and eliminate those who
got their hands on it is really you know
how this how this little bit of a
continuation goes on but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here - comments
explained make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]